hallo Chiara ich habe eine Frage an dich
zur netzwelt aktuell zum Thema ist
zurzeit ACTA was ist deine Meinung zur
Datenkrake im entferntesten betrifft es
ja auch dich beispielsweise bei der
height night ich freue mich auf deine
Antwort Ciao ich habe nicht
grundsätzlich zu allem eine Meinung ich
muss erstmal Sachen kennen bevor ich
dazu was sage ich habe jetzt in letzter
Zeit oft von akta gehört in dieser
anonym ist Bewegung die im Internet hier
für manche Unwesen treibt ich sehe das
mit einem zwiegespaltenen Gefühl auch
die Partei z.B nicht die Partei die
Piratenpartei die Partei sehe ich mit
einem eindeutig positiven gefühlt aber
in den Forderungen der Piratenpartei ist
ja auch zum Beispiel grenzenlos freies
Internet enthalten sofern ich das weiß
korrigiere mich wenn es falsch ist und
ich möchte nicht dass das Internet
grenzenlos und frei ist also es muss
schon Instanz geben wie beispielsweise
bei Verbreitung faschistischen
Gedankenguts oder Kinderpornografie
einschreitet und sagt nein das geht
nicht deswegen ich bin mir da noch nicht
ganz sicher natürlich bin ich ein
extremer Freigeist und dafür dass jeder
so weit gehen kann wie es in den
Maßstäben der regulären Moral ethischen
denke okay ist aber das kann man im
Moment noch nicht absehen wohin das geht
vielleicht ist es auch nur Spaß an der
Randale und dann wäre es schade wenn ich
in 10 Jahren mich revidieren müsste